il y a fool à la chambre des métiers et
de l'artisanat
une centaine de jeunes dirigeants a
répondu présent aubrac déj annuelle
organisée dans le cadre de la semaine de
l'artisanat
au programme une conférence sur la
performance commerciale
nicolas caron spécialiste de la
formation en management commercial était
venu transmettre son savoir faire
la salle était comble donc les gens sont
toujours intéressé et veut savoir
comment comment convaincre de nouveaux
clients dans des temps qui sont un petit
peu difficile donc l'idée c'était de
leur revenir sur des airs sur des
fondamentaux sur des idées clés ne pas
trop stresser vis-à-vis du résultat que
des passants hommes activités
commerciales du mal à maîtriser mais
voir quel est le chemin à voir les
objectifs de performance plutôt
d'objectifs de résultats et des
résultats ces jeunes dirigeants sont
demandeurs
car c'est bien lors des premières années
que les entreprises sont le plus fragile
leur apporter un éclairage sur un aspect
essentiel de la gestion d'entreprise
mais peu maîtrisée par les artisans tel
était le but de la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat
les artistes connaissent très bien leur
métier c'est le principe de base
maintenant le métier de chef
d'entreprise il est
à multiples facettes est une des plus
dures c'est le commercial donc comment
trouver un client aujourd'hui c'est pas
inné lorsqu'on a été salarié pendant
cinq dix quinze ans bah c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on apprend forcément
donc le commercial c'est peut-être ce
qui est plus dur
ces artisans sont donc venus glaner des
informations on prend des notes et on
tend l'oreille comme c'est un peu la
crise on sait pas comment on va les
chercher le client compris donc on
voulait des informations pour pour être
plus pointu comme ils disent
l'intervenant m'intéressait c'est tout
ce qui est prospection commerciale c'est
forcément très intéressant quand on
débute
et puis aussi rencontrer enfin élargir
un petit peu de réseau et rencontrer
d'autres artisans pour partager un peu
nos problématiques et les villes nos
entreprises qui débutent l'importance du
réseau un sujet bien connu de la chambre
de métiers et de l'artisanat qui
proposait à la suite de la conférence un
déjeuner ou dirigeant élu de la chambre
mais aussi partenaires bancassurance
experts ont pu échanger